[Music]
this morning we hear from two women who
say they were victims of a wave of child
abuse by Roman Catholic church leaders
in Baltimore the Maryland Attorney
General's office reviewed archdiocese
records from the 1940s through 2002. it
found more than 600 children were abused
and at least 156 people were accused of
abusing them Nikki petite spoke with two
women who say they were sexually
assaulted as teenagers by a priest and
we want to warn you some of the details
here are disturbing
for more than 50 years Teresa Lancaster
wanted the Catholic Church to believe
her Lancaster claimed that she was
sexually abused by Father Joseph maskell
at her High School in Baltimore I was 16
years old and I went to see father Masco
for some help and within the first five
minutes he took all my clothes off and
set me on his lap what were you thinking
in that moment I was in total shock
maskel was a priest who served as her
school's counselor and chaplain did you
ever report your alleged sexual abuse
not at that time because he had gotten
he would put up on his desk and he told
me that no one's going to believe you I
remember being raped by maskel Gene
hargiton Wayner says she was also abused
by maskol at the same Catholic school he
was in this pattern of manipulating
controlling and so at a certain point
all you do is what it is that you know
will make him
happy that's not going to make him mad
weiner says she reported her alleged
abuse to the Baltimore archdiocese and
these handwritten statements in 1992 she
says she was told no one had ever
complained about Masco before in the
nearly 500-page report father maskold is
accused of sexually abusing 39 people
according to the Maryland attorney
general's investigation some parishes
had multiple alleged abusers including
one with 11 over a 40-year period it was
appalling it was horrific abuse Maryland
Attorney General Anthony Brown issued
the report for many it ruined their
lives their families and as disturbing
we found a extensive cover-up in an
effort to conceal the abuse that was
happening the current Baltimore
Archbishop gave an apology calling the
abuse evil and another painful reminder
of the failings in the church's past
that was Nikki Batiste reporting father
maskel denied the allegations for years
and now he and many others have died or
are beyond the criminal statute of
limitations when Nikki spoke with Wayner
and Lancaster they said this report at
least offers some validation